[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and it seems like
we finally have some answers from the
Russo brothers about the ending of
Avengers endgame if you're still
scratching your head over whether the
old Steve Rogers that Sam encounters at
the end of the film is from an alternate
timeline or not then thankfully both
directors from the film step forward and
gave a definitive answer in an interview
with Fox v DC throughout this video I'll
be breaking down the original confusion
and discussing how Steve came to be at
the end of the movie this is full
spoilers ahead so if he's someone who
was snapped out of existence at the end
of infinity war and haven't had a chance
to watch endgame yet then I highly
recommend that you turn off now without
the way I just want to give a huge thank
you for clicking this video I hope you
enjoy it now sit back relax and let's
get into the full breakdown of the
theory okay so Avengers end game ends
with Steve Rogers travelling back in
time to return the Infinity stones and
Moliere to their rightful places but
rather than returning to the present
Steve goes back to live out the life
that he should have had with Peggy
Carter
after going through time the
old-fashioned way Steve finally sits on
the bench seemingly moments after we
traveled back so he can present his
shield for Sam and announced that he is
the new Captain America most of the main
confusion came over whether this was
actually the original Steve Rogers or if
he was from another reality going by the
rules of the film cap should have went
back in time and created a new alternate
reality however the writers of the movie
came forward and said that Steve was
actually Peggy's husband the entire time
so which one actually is it well the
following interview with the Russos
finally clears it all up
Wow alright last thing and I know you
guys have explained the multiverse a
zillion times this part I still can't
wrap my mind or a half when cap goes
back yeah where is the cap in that world
like hey so when he goes back to the
early days is there still another
Captain America in that world yes so the
the way that it would work right is that
when Captain America goes back he would
create a branch of reality right okay
now he would exist in that branch
reality
with a second caption America who was
frozen and ice so the other cat still
exists in that war so no they do not
know that other cap
wellhe's that other cap is frozen in ice
and Peggy understood that he was dead at
that point in the storytelling because
cap went back to a point in time where
nobody knew he still was alive frozen
and ice
now it's also a story for another time
as of course you created a branched
reality he would then have to use a Pym
particle to come back okay so from this
we can take the Captain America did in
fact create a branch reality and at some
point he traveled back to prime reality
in order to return the shield using a
Pym particle so the cat that we see at
the end is from the original timeline
and the one that we have followed for
the past decade or so
however the timeline that he lived in is
not the same that we have been watching
and Peggy did indeed have a different
husband to Steve Rogers in the main
reality it's sort of a bittersweet
explanation as I was kind of in the
mindset that Peggy and Steve were always
together which is why we never really
heard much about their husband however
it does also mean that he never kissed
his niece which yet I'm kind of glad
that's not the case either obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts on this and
if it's finally cleared it up for you or
if you have more questions I also just
want to let you know that we're giving
away a free copy of Avengers and game to
one lucky winner next month and all you
have to do is like this video make sure
that you subscribe to the channel and
leave your thoughts on the movie in the
comment section below
the winner will be chosen at random on
August the 10th and the blu-ray will be
shipped out from there to whoever gets
the prize best of luck to everyone who
takes part and thanks for joining in on
the channel if you want to learn more
about the model the universe then make
sure you check out the breakdown of
spider-man far from home which I've just
released and will be linked at the end
it covers all of the big questions that
you may have about the film and I go
into what I think will happen in
spider-man 3 so it's definitely worth
watching after this and I'll leave that
linked at the end
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]